大家好,很高兴今天能够给大家分享一役社区的塑胶素可信流动技术目客
今天我分享的是竖厂技术集架构
我是来自于河非纵默性国家科学中心数据工业营运的赵春玉
来自课程包括四个部分,分别是发展背景
竖技厂的技术理论,竖技教路场技术体系以及竖厂的技术架构
首先是发展背景
大的背景是整个生产要素的一个演变过程
最早从奴隶社会、红建社会都是以竹技和劳动为核心生产要素的一个农业经济
然后到了工业经济时代,随着第一次工业革命、第二次工业革命和第三次工业革命的发展
然后先后资本和技术成为了关键的生产要素
然后到了以互联网为代表的新技术加快应用,拉开了数据、数据经济时代的序幕
然后数据成为了核心的生产要素
然后在这个过程中,数据的规模呈现直数级增长
它的成本也大幅降低
然后十四届、十九届、四中小会的时候也将数据列为了关键的生产要素
第二个背景是,我们现在进入到了一个数据要素化的一个时代
但是在这个时代中,如何更好地去发挥数据的作用
如何更好地去释放数据要素的价值
其实这个其实需要数据就是来提供支撑
我们在这里面把它划分为1.0时代和2.0时代
1.0时代数据是在小范围的正习的内部去流通
然后进行数据资源的开放和共享
它的数据的规及方式是以传统的那种硬规及硬考备的方式去进行规及数据
然后提供系统内的安全防护
然后它在这个过程中也会有相应的英文软件
就是业务流程加功能级实践的比如我们的ERP
我们的Mess系统的SKAMA等等
然后到了2.0时代,它从以功能为中心
转变为了以数据为中心
数据的英文价值的状态也发生了改变
在这个过程中,数据的流通范围变得更加广泛
它的数据按照贡献去分配相关的收益
然后它是一个分布式连接的过程
它需要保证我们跨域的安全
然后数据它的属性也从资源变成了资产
然后在这个过程中完成了它的要素化
然后在这个2.0时代
它的英文也是以数据加值能体
这样的一种方式来提供它的英文
那么从懂得来看的
从1.0时代到2.0时代
去支撑数据要素价值的释放
支撑数据要素更好的去利用
它的关键就在于构建一个新型的数据设施
第二部分是数据场的理论
这个理论可以去指导和支撑
基础设施的建设和基础设施的构建
第一部分我们先来看一下数据场的定义
我们知道厂是一个物理学上的概念
厂是对时间和空间的一个函数
我们在中学的物理
物理的时候学过引力厂
学过电磁厂
我们在实体中间有质量的物体形成引力厂
比如说地球和月亮之间
地球和太阳之间都是有引力厂
电磁空间带电磁体形成电磁厂
在电磁厂的作用下带电物体形成有序运动
与各种各样的电磁效应
然后我们把这个厂和空间的概念进一步延伸
我们认为有价值数据
是不是可以形成数据场
然后在数据场作用下
在数据空间内有序的流通
然后与价值释放
回到我们数据场的定义
数据场是对数据空间中的要素
及其项目作用的基础描述
与东理学学的一个载体
然后数据场可以刻画
数据在时空上的分布去描述
数据在数据空间中运动的基本规律
然后在数据场的作用下
无序的数据有序的流通
有序的数据持续的传到价值
接着来看
在从数据空间上来讲
数据空间是一个理散的高违的空间
然后数据空间中的种类繁多
然后它们不断地进行相互作用
数据场基于数据空间
对极度复杂的几层元素进行一个建模
然后用佩佩韩素
重种化群等统计场论的方法
连接微观与宏观
对数据空间的整体的东理学性质
进行准确描述与测量
数据场用统一的韩素
标准整合数据的产生
变化 聚合 供趋 权限 隐私
交易等多内学属性
提供一整套完备的数据空间的描述与计算理论
比如说我们有人机物
然后人机物产生了各种各样的数据
然后这些数据之间
怎么去变换 怎么去聚合
怎么去使用
然后就可以用数据场的理论
去进行相关的描述
进一步地来看
数据场是有价值的数据
在特定空间内的相互作用
彼此关联所形成的一个信息空间
然后它既承载了数据本身所运行的信息
也构建了一种能够影响其他数据的样型
为状态的作用域
然后数据在场中的存在形式里作用方式
我们把它分为进数据场和感应数据场
进数据场是指静态
稳定存在的基础数据之间
构成信息环境的一个底层之声
进数据场由进取的数据要素产生
然后在这个进数据场
这一块数据要素之间的价值
产生引力 产生作用力
然后形成进数据场力
然后它是不同场景下
进数据场力的一个总和
然后感应数据场是在外部的条件
或交互行为出发下
动态生成就响应能力的场域
反映数据的生生状态
与外部环境的一个互动关系
然后感应数据场和进数据场
可以在可信流通过程中的动态演化
提供一个基础的连人框架
然后数据场它有三个的核心特征
第一个是价值连接性
数据场它的贯穿数据要素
全生命的周期
从数据的产生
产生开发治理
流通工厢 价值实现
以及安全保障等
说明周期的各环节
然后通过构建完整的价值链条
来实现数据要素的
高效流转于价值增值
第二个是动态流通性
数据场具有独特的
时空动态特性
能够促进数据要素在不同时间
空间 维度上的高效流动
保证数据价值的
及时释放有传递
第三点是协同互联性
在数据场中
数据要素不是一个孤立的存在
还是通过各种相互作用
来形成一个具有
高度协同效用的整体
我们进一步去推论
数据场相关的理论
以及相关理论的验证
我们也是从电磁场
引力场 然后到数据场
电磁场
是电流生磁 或者磁电生电
然后引力场
是惯性质量
与引力质量等价
然后我们可以推出
数据场的数据具有
非的军营性等特性
我们在这边
进一步进行
假设
在电磁场存在连续的
进市场作为相互作用媒介
引力场
引力是质量造成时工
湾区的抵核
数据场是有价值数据
形成数据场
然后在数据结构
与冬丽学
冬丽学响应这一块
要探讨的
第一个是如何将数据场
主要为
严格的数据结构
第二个是如何描述数据价值流动
因为数据场
目前还是在不断的
研究和推进之中
如果数据场假得成立的话
它也应该满足
数据结构完整性
工理之性与相关的冬丽学规则
在这一块的理论
一是什么呢
一是它可以去
指导和开拓数腰数领域
相关的研究
比如说数据是按需留动的
按需留动的
数据在高为羽翼的
结构场中的激发状态
即流动
与场景羽翼
与结构式能共同驱动
可以将数据
最小化流通面的进行封装
通过高层次抽象方法
标准化为羽翼一致
格式可结合的数据件
构成场中基本激发单元
第二个是价值的自然有限
价值是在
结构实际上
价值是在结构
时间羽翼场中的激发状态
与行为所共同决定的函数
因此价值在数据
与模型
场景羽翼之间的作用
逐步的能够有限
不要数据的
典型的价值施放模式
构建面向高羽翼结构的价值抽象
以度量框架
引导供需双方在市场中
实现一个动态的一个进价居行
第二个
基础体系
在前面
基础理念之上
进不去构建
一个数据产的一个基础体系
数据产的基础体系
首先
它是覆盖数据要素的
全生命中期环节
从它数据的产生
搭达了治理
流通 处理 安全 等等
完整的覆盖数据层产生
到最后利用
一个数据行为过程中的
方方面面
然后
我们可以把它盖过为五块
分别是
原子画的封装
全域画的治理
低伤化的流通
巨变设置处理及
产动式的安全
然后 基于数据要素产这样的一个
基础体系
就可以实现刚才数据产提到的
实现无需的数据
持续的来
创造价值
右边是
整个数据要素产体系的一个架构
包括
数据建的封装技术
跨域的数据治理技术
巨变式的
处理技术
低伤化的流通技术
穿透式的安全技术
等等
数据建封装技术最快
又包括
关联发现
以及我们标准化的封装
跨域治理这块就包括我们跨域的
一域融合 跨域的查学
全域的隐私保护
然后 低伤化的流通技术
包括我们场景画的定价
我们定制化的供需匹配
我们规范化的交易流程
然后 巨变式的处理技术
包括我们广泊化的数据融合
然后 整治化的心理体链
协同化的鸡蛋框架等等
以穿透式的安全技术
然后 我们穿透的黑盒解释
跨域的公式和监管
我们全联络的渗透检测
等等
首先来看
我们数据建的
封装技术
它是一种基于
一组标准 协议
以机制设计形成的一整套
一寻止
一交换 一操作的
数据建标准化
封装发达
我们首先来分析一下
我们为什么会提出
这样的一个技术
我们在交通物流领域
我们很多
很多商品 很多物品
其实是基于
一个标准化的集装箱
去运输的
有了这样一个标准化的集装箱
我们在物流转运
整个运出过程中
会特别的方便和快捷
比如说我们从海运
到我们的内核的航运
到我们的铁路运输
在整个过程中
我们使用集装箱运输的话
是特别的
方便和快捷的
代表说
水
我们水在
流通运输的时候
也是有一个
标准化的一个容器来成装的
我们有各种各样的一个
各种各样的一个瓶装水
就是因为
是在数据
流通和共享的过程中
数据的组织形态
是不一样的
是有各种各样的
有各种各样的组织形态
数据
然后有不同的
不同的文件
不同的格式 不同的形态等等
然后在这样的一个
不同的组织和不同的形态
它其实真的是不利于
这个流通和使用的
然后
我们在这种背景下就提供
提供一种标准化的
封装方法
我们把所有的数据
或者说我们在
我们在这个流通过程中的数据
我们都把它封装成一个
标准化的一个构建
我们把它称为数据箭
然后数据箭是
可以让数据可计量
可以让数据在
然后它比如说包括
我们统一的
表征模型
然后在这个表征和过程中
我们会给它
定义统一的
描述语言
然后定义
统一的语义
然后我们在整个封装过程中
也会使用
高效的一个存储结构
用来优化
数据的存储
然后在整个
封装的过程中
也会采用相关的安置
包括同态加密
查分隐私
全线配置等等
然后通过这样的一个
封装和构造
我们得到了一个数据
标准化的一个流通单元
它也是可以满足
分布式数据流通的一个需求
然后有了这样的一个
标准化的数据流通单元
数据构建
就可以让机器
更快的读懂数据
然后
占用的资源也更爽
可以更快
更高效的去进行
广域的大规模的
数据流通
最终可以实现
我们提升数据的价值
提升语义的统一
提升高效的减缩
等等
我们数据流通的一个需求
第2个
是跨域数据治理技术
它是
构建统一高效的
跨域数据管理系统
实现语义的融合
数据查询的可统一
数据协作的可信任
首先我们来看一个跨域的概念
什么是跨域呢
我们
非常容易理解
在地理空间上的跨域
比如说不同的省份
数据在不同的省份
不同区域之间
这个跨域
跨空间域
还有一种是跨域是什么跨域
在工作中有不同的条线
不同的条线
比如说有不同的行业
自然自然
我们的金融交通
在不同的条线
我们有不同的管车范围
然后不同的管车范围
它对数据的安全的
要求也是不一样的
我们这个时候把它称为跨管车
管车域
然后还有一种跨域
是什么跨域呢
就是说我数据
我在有某一个范围内流通
我对这个范围内的主体
我是信任的
但是当数据脱离了这个范围的时候
脱离了这个范围内的时候
脱离了这些
这些主体的时候
然后这个时候
我作为数据提供者
提供方来讲
我对其他超出了我这个范围内的
我是不信任的
我们把它叫做跨信任域
然后大概是这样的一种
跨域的一个解释
然后再在跨域
数据在跨域流通中
它可能就会有各种各样的一个问题
比如说我们怎么进行跨域的融合
跨域的融合
这块呢主要是解决
跨域数据
与意志性的一个问题
然后来构建一个跨域
统一的数据的
与意层面的一个模型
比如说
我们针对同一个东西
在不同的空间域
不同的空间域
它有不同的表达方式
但是在某一些行业
某些领域
它对与盐和与意的经营的要求是
不允许出现一个字的误差
因为如果出现了
那个数据在
数据在跨域传递过程中
如果出现了
误差可能造成非常非常严重的
后果
现在可能造成一些医疗事故
这一块
这就是我们讲的那个跨域数据融合技术
包括我们那个
主要是与意的融合
然后跨域系列查询技术
针对
因为我们刚刚讲了几个跨域
我们跨空间域
我们跨管辖域
然后针对跨域多方的
资源益购
我们提供一种益购资源的感知
然后
和那个跨域的查询性的优化技术
来实现
查得快
因为就比如说我们不同的
不同的那个
数据
益购
它可能就是说
造成我们有时候是
没有办法查询的
或者说我们查询的特别特别慢
已经影响了我们工作的一个效率
然后
还有一种是
跨域的数据
数据协作技术
然后针对
跨域数据
数据保护
因为就我们
不同的数据
在我们不同的
管辖范围
在我们不同的主体
它有不同的保护方式
然后这时候
我们提出了一种
基于那个算子的
协同的计算方法
来促进和支撑
跨域数据的协作
第三个是
低伤化的
低伤化的流通技术
然后通过需求指引
价值指导
供需缩和
来构建一个有序
高效
结构化的多元的
一个数据叫做流通生态
第一个是
场景化的使用定价技术
在当前的
当前的数据
流通交易的一种
其实数据价值的
评估数据的定价
还面临着一些问题
因为它数据有
有它不同于
传统的生态要素的
数据特征
亦复制
可以无限的复制
然后它
还有实效性
还有非实体性
等等这样的一个特征
这样的一些特征
都给数据的定价
造成了一些阻碍
而且就是说
同一个数据
它
当它在
不同的场景去使用的时候
它的价值可能也是不一样的
然后在这一块
我们就体重了
一种
场景化的数据定价方法
然后针对数据价值场景
依赖的定价能
建立
场景化的数据要素定价机制
实现数据定价的可视力
然后第二个
是消货式的
需求挖掘
我们刚才有提到了
数据资源
是呈现指数级增长的
就是随着
我们数据化的推进
我们各种各样的企业机构
以及个人
都积累了大量的
数据资源
但是有些数据资源
它
还没有找到
它能够去使用它的地方
也就是说
在这一块
需求其实是
挖掘的是不够
不够深入的
需求其实是
还没有去匹配
找到匹配它的
匹配它的一个数据
针对数据
需求表达模糊挖掘难
然后我们这边
建立一个交货式的一个需求
挖掘机制
实现数据
需求可表示
然后通过
虚方的认知
和共方的认知
来去挖掘他们
在认知层面的一个差异
更好的去
去匹配它的一个需求
来满足数据的一个需求
来更多去挖掘数据的一个价值
然后定制化了一个
一个供需匹配
我针对
我们买方数据买方的一个
一个需求
针对我们
我们卖方关于数据的
一个描述
然后来通过
我们挣的话的一个匹配
来实现
我们数据的供应
能够高效的去满足数据
买方的一个需求
然后来建立这样的一个
供需匹配机制
实现一个高效的数据
供防和虚方的一个
高效的匹配
穿透式的安全技术
第四部分
字面向速要素流通的
数据信息指使
三大流通链路
实现数据安全的可追溯
计算安全的可验证
模型安全的可解释
它可以穿透数据流通链路中
各方
各环节的一个
安全保障理论和技术
实现
市中
市前
厂内和厂外
多方的一个安全分析和防御
第一个是一个多摩泰的
一个数据指纹和
以自检测技术
因为我们现在
使用的一些
个人数据
企业数据
它可能设立到一些
个人椅子信息
和商业秘密
有一些东西
可能是不符合
个人心理保护法
和网络安全法的一些
交情人
这个是我们需要把
里面的一些关键信息
给它检测出来
然后这时候
它匹配了我们
所有进入我们这个体系内的
我们都会给数据
添加一个指
然后能够实现
全链路的一个
全链路的一个追踪
然后第二个是
多场景的
高效的以自检测理论和技术
然后我们这一块
构建了三层
分别是我们的
支撑层 算子层和应用层
支撑层包括我们的
比较定路 随机置换
不经意便利
共享 置换 升层等等
然后算子层
包括我们的
聚合函做条件与据等等
来遵守我们
真实查军的与据
我们基于规则的
组合设略等等
来满足我们
在高满足
我们在隐私
条件下的一个
高效的计算
然后还有我们是
多方参与的
一个以自检测
多方参与学习的
一个以自检测技术
来满足我们
一些场景下
对以自的一个要求
俱变式的处理技术
然后它是
融合多种数研究理论
以技术推动
数腰速在
复杂的数据
进价交易环境中
数据价值的估计与衡量
包括我们广泊化的数据
融合
层次化的
层级化的新一体链
以及鞋动化的
计算框架
通过
广泊化的数据
融合这一块
通过数据要素的
广泊化的数据融合
可以我们
研究
适应多样市场
环境的一个
估值技术
然后层级化的
新一体链
通过
对买家行为
和经济机制进行
博弈节目语院证
然后来提出一个
基于
层级化新一体链的
一个
进价机制
鞋动化的计算框架
然后通过
构建数据要素交易
模拟环境
利用博弈论
智能体技术
然后来提出
进价与军合的
实现
数据进价与
数据进价的一个均衡
然后
第四部分
是我们
收场的一个技术价格
首先来看一下
它的基本概念
根据
数据进价指引
收场是
一拖开放性网络
算理和影子保护
7块链
等各类关联功能设施
面向数据要素
提供线上线下
资源登记
供需区培
交易流通开发利用
存用资源等功能
支撑多长年
应用的一种综合性
数据流通利用技术设施
在数据技术
进价指引里面
它提到的
六种技术路线
分别是
评书流通间
数链网
数场
隐私计算
7块链
数据远念等等
然后数场
也是六个核心的
技术路线之一
然后它的目标
是实现数据的
高效流通
价值的释放
一个繁荣的生态
能力这一块
是可以实现
可见
可打
可用
可控
可追溯
它的特点是
有融合性
开放性
和拓展性
然后
现在随着
技术路线的收敛
出厂
其实也在不断的
和肯定数据空间
数链网等等
多种技术路线
进一步的去融合
然后更好地去支撑
整个数据技术设施
建设
以及数据要求
场景的应用
和价值的释放
我们前面提到了
数据场和数据要求场
然后现在我们开始讲
数场
然后他们之间的一个关系
其实是
基础理论
基础体系
基础设施的一个关系
然后数据场是一个
基础理论
它提供一个
机制
以及在相关
动力学特性上的
一个描述
然后它可以来支撑
数据要求场
技术体系的一个构建
然后它包含了
刚才我介绍的
五大技术模块
然后
技术理论和技术体系
可以来支撑数场
基础设施的一个建设
它是这样的一个关系
然后我们再来看一下
它的一个
概念架构
前面我们在
数据场的时候
我们提到就是说
现在整个
整个
整个社会
它有
各种各样的
主体
各种各样的主体
然后
随着数字化的不断推进
各种各样的主体
不断地去产生数据
人在产生数据
机器在产生数据
相关的物体在产生数据
然后
这样的一些
产生数据的一个
一个源头
把它叫做截点
截点不断地在产生
产生各种各样的数据
然后数据
截点它是可以通过我们
网络的链接
通过我们的专线
我们的虚拟网络
虚拟网络
把这些相关的截点
连接在
连接在一起
然后
我们占了一些截点
连接在一起之后
我们就是
从数据的产生
到我们最后数据的应用
有这样的一个过程
从我们的设断之里
存庄登记
我们的数据封装
数据交换
应用消费等等
有这样的一个完整链条
最后在服务于
我们各种各样的场景
服务于我们的卫生健康场景
服务于我们的工业场景
服务于我们的金融场景
交通场景等等
然后我们再回过来看
那么就是数据
从它的截点
到连接
再到数据的再生产
再到数据的一个价值释放
也就是说数据
它产生于人机物
最后也作用于人机物
这是一个整体上的一个
概念上的一个架构设计
整体架构上来讲
输场
它有点
点
线
面和场
然后点就是我们的
接入连接器
我们接入连接器
连接我们的截点
然后截点就是
我们刚才讲的人机物
人机物它产生数据
接入连接器
它又分为标准版
我们把它分为标准版
基础版
标准版 拓展版和增强版
接入连接器可以连接
政府 企业 个人等等
就是在点这一层面
然后数据使用方和数据提供方
这一块它在连接器的功能上
可能上有一些区别
它在整体上是一致的
然后点与点之间
就是数据提供方和数据使用方之间
可以通过我们的
告诉我们的数据网络连接
我们的数据分发网络进行连接
也就是我们的线
然后在面上
是我们的平台体系
我们的平台体系
包括我们的数场的管理平台
我们数场的数据流通利用平台
我们数场的技术之中平台
然后面与点之间
也是通过我们的线
去连接的
通过我们的高度数据网
通过我们的数据分发网络
去连接数场的平台体系
也就是我们的面
然后在最上层的
场的一层面
就是实现了我们数据的价值
利用我们的场景的建设
可以服务于我们的
城市治理
服务于我们的应急管理
公共健康
卫生健康
社会文理
普会金融等等
然后这呢
是构成了我们一个
数场的一个
总体的一个架构
包括我们的面
场
以及我们点与点之间的关系
点与线之间的关系
面与点之间的关系
然后面与场之间的一个关系
然后点与点之间的
它可以通过我们的
线去连接
通过我们的网络连接
然后点与面之间的
也就是通过我们的
高度数据网
与数据分发网络去连接
然后这些呢
点线面呢
对我都支撑于我们
长径的利用
长径的建设
以及数据价值的思考
数场呢
然后它的数据
就是总的一个角色
和定位是什么呢
就是
我们刚才提到了
由于现在数据组练用
它有六种集中路线
然后数场也是其中
其中之一
也是一个比较合心的
集中路线
而且现在也在不断的和
其他集中路线进行融合
我们再看
我们看中间
这是一个数据
就是整体的一个
功能试图
它包括了算力
设施
流通利用
安全保障以及
智能设施接流层
这样的一整合体系
我们看我们
数据流通利用设施
从这一块
从我们最底下的
最底下的接入连接器
这一块
接入连接器
数场呢
它也有数场接入连接器
因为接入连接器
它有不同的版本
从我们的基础版
基础版标准版
我们的拓展功能
当数场的接入连接器
它具有接入连接器
去最基本的要求
最基本的要求
然后它在最基本的要求之上
拓展了数场的一些
拓展了数场的一些技术功能
我们在这一块
我们就把它
叫做数场的接入连接器
同理呢
还有那个数连网的接入连接器
有那个隐私鸡蛋的接入连接器等等
然后在接入连接器
上层呢
是我们的业务节点
业务节点
包括我们的区域
数据流通利用平台
我们的公共服务平台
企业数据流通利用平台
行业数据流通利用平台
等等
这一半呢
其实就是我们数场的
流通利用平台
然后在上层呢
是节点
包括我们的权益功能节点
区域功能节点
以行业功能节点
我们的区域功能节点
以及行业功能节点呢
其实就是我们数场的
一个基础支撑平台
然后权益功能节点呢
其实就是我们的数场的
一个管理平台
管理平台
这样是一个数场
在整个基础设计中的
一个功能和定位
也可以和我们前面
讲到的那个
加购联系起来
然后从
功能层面上
来讲
然后
从节点
到连接
到流通
到释放
节点呢是
是包括我们的
数据的持有方
我们数据的第三方
我们数据的需求方
我们的服务方等等
然后节点呢是通过
我刚才提到的
数场的接入连接器
进行连接的
它也就是我们的点
然后连接呢
连接呢
包括我们的高速数据网
高速数据网
我们的数据的分发
数据的分发网络
连接
连接我们节点与节点之间
连接我们节点与
与面之间与平台之间
然后再上层呢是我们的
流通
流通我们的
我们的数据
从原始数据
进行标准化的封装
变成了一个数据键
然后在这里面
我们进行一个
跨意管理聚合使用
加工利用行程
数据产品
然后在这一块呢
也有我们那个数据
统一的交换模型
我们数据的统一标识
来支持
然后数据
在这个过程中
也有我们相关的服务的支持
我们贡献缩和的支持
我们济费济粮的支持
我们产品交付的支持
等等
然后这一块就是
我们面上的一个流通
最后在厂上面
就是我们数据价值的
价值的释放
我们
我们可以
呈成治理
迹象服务
应急管理
医疗健康
文化理由
金融服务等等
然后在这个过程中
还有各种各样的安全
包括身份的存证的
感知的密码等等
以及相关的管控
包括国家层面的监管
以及行业的监管等等
然后在系统层面
我们把它分成
四个层
分为是我们的介入层
工能层 业务层
管理层
其实也是和前面的架构
对应起来的
介入层
这是我们的塑厂的
结合了一起
我们把它分成了
分成了三个版本
包括我们的基础能力
标准能力和拓展能力
基础能力
包括我们的身份认证
标准能力
包括在我们的身份认证之上
又包括我们的法文控制
我们的数据介入
我们的支持记录
数据交付 运营商大商办等等
然后拓展能力
在标准能力的记录之上
就加了登记 探查 杀箱
开发 目录管理 以资计单节点
分类分析 使用控制
高度数据网等等
然后我们在部署和使用的时候
根据我们的数据主体
它数据规模的大小
它的身份
它使用场景的一些要求
我们来可以去部署和匹配
不同版本
不同能力的一个数场的
接入连接器
然后在功能层面
就是我们数场的技术支撑平台
可以来实现我们
统一的身份管理
统一的数据目录
统一的标识管理
统一的数据登记
连接器管理 运营监测等等
而有了我们加了一个数场
基础支撑平台
对上我们可以与
国家的权益功能节点
进行对接
然后呢
横向呢
我们可以与其他的
其他一个技术设施
包括隔音数据公司
锁链网进行横向的一个连通
进行横向的数据的互联互动
和互操作
然后在业务层面
是我们的数据流通利用平台
它包括我们的数据交易系统
数据开发系统
数据运营系统
区块链公共服务
以资金散
托管 训练场
数据交付
囤中审计
隔音溯源等等
然后这个呢
可以给我们的数据供需方
我们的数据服务方
来提供相关的服务
来使得整个数据
整个数据
应用了一个支撑
然后管理层呢
就是我们的收藏管理平台
可以与我们的收藏技术之争
平台进行对接
也可以去
管理我们其他的一些
其他的一些收藏的技术之争
然后上层呢
就是我们更具体的
一些长进的
长进的一些应用
然后伴随着我们
整个
整个生命周期和系统设计
还有我们的一个
安全的保障的一个体系
这就是我们收藏
在系统层面的一个价格和设计
然后我以医疗健康
数据融合卡拉利用为例
讲一下这个怎么去
怎么去进行
收藏的
长进应用呢
比如说在
首先我们在那个数据层面
我们通过我们
通过我们不同
通过我们的收藏接入领先器
去接入
接入我们的数据
提供房
接入我们的数据使用房
以及接入我们的数据的
服务房和监管房等等
然后这是第一步
然后呢
这些
这些收藏的接入领先器
通过我们的数据专网
通过我们的
通过我们的区议数据网络
进行连接
然后这个数据得到了
得到了我们的
进行了相关的授权
然后确定了相关的安全策略
然后进行了
标准化的购建封装
封装成了一个
封装成了一个标准化的一个
数据购建
也就是一个
医疗健康领域的一个数据件
然后进行那个连接器的
一个可信
可信组网
然后在在管理层
数据管理层完成的
然后呢
就是在
在数据
网络层到管理层完成的
然后在进一步的进行就是
予以者换
然后提供一个
安全的一个
环境
安全的一个环境
来保证整个数据使用
过程中的一个安全
包括我们
进行协同的计算
集中式的可信计算等等
然后
最后我们按照
我们使用的
安全策略
我们使用的策略
我们约定的策略
进行数据产品的
检查
如果整个
使用过程已经完成的话
我们再进行相关的
数据销毁
然后呢
基于我们这样一套体系
我们可以再打造
打造我们的疾病诊疗模型
疾病诊疗模型
我们的
智能问诊模型
然后在整个
数据使用的过程中
涉及到我们的数据的
提供法
提供法我们相关的
医疗机构等等
我们数据的服务法
以及我们数据的使用法
来这样
通过这样的一整套流程
来完成一个医疗数据的
融合开发的利用过程
以上就是我的分享
谢谢大家